we have a trailer for thor love and
thunder and you clicked here to know my
thoughts maybe you were curious about my
thoughts maybe you were like did he cut
his hair today which before we get to
throw 11 thunder gotta address this very
important thing i've seen more comments
lately of people like why does he still
have long hair look simply put i have
the hair i have for the same reason one
would comment that question why a dog
licks his balls
because
i
can glad we cleared that up thor love
and thunder so this trailer starts out
showing that thor has kind of reached
this impasse in his life he's reached
this moment where he's like what do i
actually want to do with my life just
funny because the avengers it just seems
like such a pinnacle it's like oh hey
that's the end game obviously it's one
of them's title end game but in a world
where chatter is chatter my friends it's
not like the mcu is going to be like
biggest film franchise in history guess
we'll stop now no the show must go on so
all this avengers team-up thing it was
just kind of a phase in these characters
lives some married peggy carter retired
some went down like heroes thor's like i
that was a phase of my life that was
when i was part of the group band now
i'm going solo thor's timberlake
essentially which the bummer of the
whole thing is it looks like where it
left off an end game it was thor and
guardians of the galaxy the asgardians
of the galaxy as people called it
including thor kind of an exciting
dynamic though i always felt bad for
peter quill because thor always
emasculated him in front of his crew i
was like thor i thought you weren't a
dick anymore remember thor won would you
learn to be nice except to peter quill
porquelle but it looks like he pals
around with him at the beginning has a
funny moment in the trailer with it then
he's like nah i'm out i'm gonna go find
myself blast out of there with at least
one star wanted rating for jack in their
car it looks like you know he goes world
the world i don't know how many worlds
he goes to could just be one but as i
don't know it kind of looks like the
plot of voyage of the dawn shredder is
just going to place to place and new
adventures i guess not they're just a
bad thing sounds like an insult when i
say it like that like voyage of the dawn
treader is part of
classic literature which this trailer
doesn't have a lot of action in it
really no real action in it you see thor
working out with the ropes by ropes i
mean chains looking like he's forrest
gump running across the country which i
mean i get that fat thor was never
sustainable you know you can't have him
be fat thor forever it's just kind of
the funny joke and end game but i gotta
say that braided beard was legit i wish
they kept that look and now he's the
most jacked he's ever been he looks like
arnold from t1 he's like i don't want to
fight anymore i don't want to be a god i
need to find myself and it does point
out the fact it's like dude come on
god's got to get bored they do get bored
when they get bored usually in mythology
they just [ __ ] with humans even odin's
like i don't know i guess i'll just you
know die for a little bit every so often
that'll keep things fresh and
interesting i mean if you live that long
yeah career change has got to be in the
works it's got to be in the cards
somewhere as much as i do understand all
that i hope they don't professor hulk
thor like professor hull funny for a
movie and then you think about it you're
like that dual identity monster within
dynamic gone like that's less
interesting for me i love the tagline in
this trailer though not every god has a
plan as a good looking man once said
god's a kid with an ant farm lady he's
not planning anything we get a quick
glimpse of jane foster thor or jayden
foster god of thunder i don't know the
official name those are not comic books
i read hope they explain how thor's very
human ex-girlfriend jane foster passed
up lady siff and that god of thunder
promotion looks like nepotism to me her
arms are [ __ ] enormous though jeez
cracking walnuts some props to her put
in that work which it looks like zeus is
in this movie which god of thunder god
of thunder could be really creative
question i have my head is in eternals
some of the characters in the eternals
were what greek mythology greek gods
were based off of but now you have zeus
like an actual greek god who looks
pretty godly in here is he an eternal is
zeus an eternal or were the eternals in
the eternals were they like god posers
like there's an actual athena out there
who's not this athena didn't seem to be
the case in the eternals it looked like
these characters were what greek
mythology and other mythology is
actually like gilgamesh and whatnot it's
what they were based off of again don't
expect an answer for that but it's just
it's something that's like hey i'm in
your head and then you know i'll be gone
because i'll be on to thinking about
other things like in the end thor love
and thunder it's a really good teaser
trailer gives you some tone shows you
the gist doesn't show you too much about
the plot it looks beautiful in the song
choice my god sweet child of mine yeah
there are always concerns with me in a
situation like this it's like are you
trying to nerf thor but for that we'll
see how the movie goes but this trailer
was a good one all right so the teaser
trailer for thor 11 thunder have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you